hello I'm Xena Badawi welcome to this
intelligence squared debate coming to
you from Cadogan Hall in central London
it's exactly 10 years ago that 9/11
happened nearly 3,000 people were killed
in those attacks in America and they
changed the course of world history
forever the motion in our debate a
decade on was the war on terror the
right response to 9/11 and in our panel
we have some of the key figures from
that time pervez musharraf
was president of pakistan he is arguing
for the motion along with colleen graphi
who served in the Bush administration
arguing against the motion so Jeremy
green stock who was the senior British
diplomat at the time and the influential
French politician dr. Bernard Kushner
that's our panel welcome to you
as you our audience were coming in you
are asked to vote to see where you stand
on the motion right now then each of our
panel members will make their opening
statements to you then you will have a
chance to put questions or even make
comments indeed to our panel members and
we will ask you to vote again to see if
you've perhaps changed your mind and
where the votes there stands so I hope
that's all clear we can start our debate
arguing for the motion the war on terror
was the right response to 9/11 pervez
musharraf who was president of pakistan
from 1999 until 2008 and of course he
was a crucial figure in the war on
terror particularly when it came to the
invasion of neighboring Afghanistan
General Musharraf
in September 2001 ladies and gentlemen
the world leaders and I happen to be one
of them had to decide whether fighting
the war on terror would make the world a
safer place to live in I then believed
and still do believe that we had and
continue to have even now a
responsibility to act decisively to root
out terrorism we need to be clear that
the call for action was certainly not
based on the single incident of 9/11
9/11 in fact was the catalyst the
culmination of a series of increasingly
bloody terrorist outrages which finally
tipped the scales against the prevalent
law enforcement approach it roused
universal condemnation and forced the
strong action against terror
ladies and gentlemen terror has to be
defeated there is no running away from
it the destructive power of the
explosive and the viciousness of the
suicide bombers who bring misery to
people at large to innocent people at
large has to be combated holistically
the war on terror has three fronts the
military the political and the
socio-economic we have a tendency to
overuse the military instrument to pay
lip service to the socio-economic and
almost ignore the political element it
is this shortsightedness of the past
that perhaps saved al Qaeda from defeat
I have two arguments to justify the
statement that I have just made firstly
had the world recognized the Taliban
after 1996 when they controlled more
than 90 percent of Afghanistan maybe we
could have Madhuri
did them from within now coming to the
second misc
political opportunity the aftermath of
the military success of the 9/11
response had to be capitalized with the
shift and the application of the
political instrument al-qaeda and their
betters the Taliban were defeated were
militarily defeated and they were in
total disarray their organizational and
command structure was dismantled in
Afghanistan in and they ran helter
skelter into the mountains and cities of
Pakistan but truly representative
national government which gave
proportional representation to all the
ethnic groups could have brought peace
into Afghanistan and maybe also out
stood al Qaeda ladies and gentlemen the
complexity of terrorism has increased
now their center of gravity lies in
Afghanistan and the tribal agencies of
Pakistan we have to defeat them at the
center of gravity losing here means
defeat elsewhere and everywhere in
conclusion ladies and gentlemen may I
say that we can criticize we can
disagree with the conduct with the
execution with the handling of the war
on terror but the world cannot absolve
itself from its collective
responsibility of fighting and defeating
the war and defeating terrorism in the
world thank you very much
arguing against the motion our next
speaker sir jeremy green stock he was
the UK's representative at the United
Nations for five years including during
2001 and then in 2003 he became the UK
special representative in Iraq after the
overthrow of Saddam Hussein and he
continues to influence thinking on
foreign policy still through his
writings and his work
so Jeremy green start your time starts
when you get to the left
ladies and gentlemen we have just heard
a supreme military leader defending the
use of military means to overcome a
threat that for all its use of violence
was not military indeed the threat is
all the more powerful because it comes
from methods of attack that aim to
neutralize to the greatest extent
possible the vast military superiority
of the target to fine-tune the response
to an attack you have to understand what
the attack was all about and who was
behind it al-qaeda's fundamental purpose
in planning 9/11 and other attacks on
American and Western interests was to
create a situation in the Islamic world
in which a particular many would say a
bizarre interpretation of Islam could
thrive politically and religiously
enticing the world's only superpower
into a war or a series of wars in the
Middle East was seen as the route to
social and political chaos there out of
which something new could emerge with
enough popular support to be sustainable
making the United States so angry has to
be prone to miss judgments such as the
doctrine of preventive war was an
essential step in this design in the
global picture this was about more than
terrorism Washington on a war footing
then made a mistake which played into Al
Qaeda's hands Al Qaeda's recognition
that the u.s. might be goaded into
becoming a hammer looking for a nail was
proved accurate in the u.s. decision to
invade and occupy Iraq in 2003
when Iraq had nothing to do with 9/11
now is not the time for a detailed
analysis of the effects of the Iraq
decision but it's my belief
that the war in Iraq has complicated our
capacity to deal with terrorism
internationally and expanded the range
of pretexts for terrorists to use
violence both against the West and
against fellow Muslims in short if the
war on terror was the right response
then terrorism after trillions of
dollars of expenditure on military
operations and hundreds of thousands of
deaths should be on its last legs too
many people saw the u.s. as taking
forward a war of its own conception and
in in its own national interests without
addressing the concerns of others the
opportunity for the Americans to lead a
global collective approach to security
issues was lost the new counterterrorism
of the Obama administration is
interesting to observe largely
recognizes and seeks to correct that
original misconception of what
counterterrorism should be all about
strong precise action to deal with
criminal groups has to be combined with
diplomacy and partnership is what that
new strategy says and that's quite a
different approach from a war on terror
it's hard to avoid the conclusion that
the United States made this change much
too late let's show in your vote tonight
that we have at least learned that
lesson thank you very much
the Jerry McQueen stock thank you very
much indeed
arguing for the motion we now have
Colleen graphi who was an assistant
secretary of state in the US State
Department in george w bush's second
term calling graphi your time starts
when you get to the podium
the war on terror was the right response
to 9/11 the fact is the military
approach has worked in the decades since
9/11 al Qaeda's actions have not kept
pace with their aspirations coordinated
attacks of a global reach have fallen
and we are working so that it remained
so we learned from recently recovered
documents that Osama bin Laden was
lamenting from his bunker that the drone
strikes were preventing training and
reducing capable leadership the fact
that war was the right response to 9/11
is reinforced by the fact that the Obama
administration after great scrutiny and
great deliberation has actually consent
continued on the same course in fact
he's increased drone strikes nothing
short of war was needed to get at the
root causes of terrorism and the root
causes of terrorism are the Middle East
dictators and tyrants who sucked the air
out of public discourse and prevent the
development of civil society this leaves
only mosques as the place for people to
vent unfortunately it is also the place
where people are radicalized into a
perverted version of Islam which hopes
to replace one tyranny with another
their own for 60 years the United States
desire for stability was more important
than pushing for democratic reforms in
the Middle East the war on terror led to
a significant and strategic change in
the u.s. foreign policy one that allowed
for America's vital interests and
deepest beliefs to become one it led to
the freedom agenda which was committed
to supporting the Democratic aspirations
of all people nothing short of war would
have changed the power structures in
Afghanistan and Iraq and make no mistake
the change
was a catalyst for what we see today the
Arab Spring and the crumbling of tyrants
from Tunisia to Egypt Libya and
hopefully more to come don't take it
from me listen to a voice from the
region Lebanese political leader Walid
Shoebat during Lebanon's 2005 cedar
revolution said it's strange for me to
say it but this progress of change has
started because of the American invasion
of Iraq I was cynical about Iraq but
when I saw the Iraqi people voting three
weeks ago 8 million of them it was the
start of a new Arab world the Syrian
people
the Egyptian people all say that
something is changing the Berlin Wall
has fallen we can see it to our Western
eyes Afghanistan and Iraq alternate
between depressing and discouraging with
glimmers of hope in between but to those
in the Middle East who have only lived
under tyrants and thought that this was
the way it was and always would be
seeing the end of Saddam Hussein was the
first crack in the edifice with the end
of his regime a man who represented the
ultimate symbol of despotic rule in the
region came the prospect that other
regimes other Saddam's may also fall the
cold war the war on terror the overseas
contingency operation the name is
secondary to the nature of what each
represents a commitment to overturning
tyranny and the freeing of the human
spirit the war on terror was the right
response to 9/11
thank you very much indeed Colleen
graphy and our final speaker in these
opening statements is dr. Burton our
Koosh nerdy french socialist politician
until the end of last year he was
France's foreign minister in the
government of the center-right President
Nicolas Sarkozy during 9/11 he was
serving in the French cabinet as health
minister dr. Kirchner
so the war on terror was it the right
answer to 9/11
honestly this is difficult to say yes or
no completely saturate yes it was
imperative to react to 9/11 by war are
you asking for an ethical a military or
a political judgment let me be blunt
ethically it was imperative for the u.s.
to react
politically the way the Bush
administration did has not been a
complete success ten years after what
was the real goals to defeat bin Laden
al Qaeda now is dead his organization
may be weakened but it survived and some
say proliferates in Africa
I remember the horrified moment of 9/11
we our American friends and their allies
we had to respond and to fight back but
not only by force and I'm not so far
President Musharraf said it should have
been also a war against poverty poverty
is the main world in Afghanistan and
also in Pakistan in chasing bin Laden
Western leaders discovered a reality
that only those remembering the Soviet
war knew Afghanistan is a patchwork of
tribes starting with the Pashtun more or
less close to the Taliban and more or
less linked to bin Laden the Pashtun
leaves on both side of two countries
there are no border between Afghanistan
and Pakistan the Pashtun move freely so
should we have to make war on Pakistan
impossible two good reasons the
Pakistanis are supposed to be our allies
and they have atomic weapons there is
only one certainty the US and its allies
cannot win this war militarily our
public opinion will not tolerate for
long to see coffins coming back home for
no clear purpose and there is also one
fact Ben Laden is dead and he was killed
in Pakistan we must absolutely and
Jeremy was very good on that make the
distinction in between the so-called war
on terror and the war in Iraq was Saddam
a respectable leader certainly not he
was a dictator and the butcher of his
own people in February 2003 I wrote an
article in the moment it was a big noise
in France no to Saddam no to the war so
the real issues in conclusion today ten
years after 9/11 how the people of
Afghanistan and the people of Iraq any
better off yes in a way schools
education hospital roads etc we looked
at the wrong generation
I believe that this is part of the
answer resides in the hopes of the Arab
Spring and Allah young Arab leaders
thank you very much
thank you very much so you've heard from
our speakers it's now at the turn of the
audience but before we take questions
and comments from you let me just tell
you how you all voted as you were coming
into the Cadogan hall today
so our motion the war on terror was the
right response to 9/11 this is how you
voted for the motion a hundred and
seventy nine against the motion that's
your side 323 don't be too quick because
the don't knows our 200 so panel there's
a great door you can do your side you
can try your best you can try your best
to win over those two hundreds who don't
know so let's go there yep after 9/11
there was an outpouring of goodwill
toward of the United States I want to
suggest you that that outpouring of
sympathy was wasted but what would have
been much better in order to get so many
of the Arab countries on side for any
kind of war on terror was a resolution
to the israeli-palestinian conflict
without that no Arab country could
possibly have joined in a war on terror
because of the bitterness resentment
caused by the prior to the Palestinians
thank you we'll come to in a moment one
more and then what your opinion was on
the Obama administration's drone attacks
in Pakistan which have increased quite a
lot recently and whether you condone
them okay one more government ban a
burqa in French yeah that act sporting a
terrorism 100% yeah while you intervene
in the personal behavior of Muslims so
what you think is Western not supporting
a terrorism by putting that kind of
sanctions so your question is the French
have banned the wearing of the the veil
yeah so by doing these kind of things
it's not that kind of act promoting a
terrorism in the east right okay well
dr. Schnurr you can make that connection
extremism must be defeated to compare
extremism in the Middle East in between
Palestinian Israelis and in the Middle
East generally speaking was not right
and at the beginning of bin Laden
terrorism it was not question of that
but if you want me to say and we will be
all in agreement that we must set up a
real peace that is to say to recognize a
Palestinian state etc yes we are - and
we try but honestly it's very far from
the reality of Pakistan Afghanistan and
the rest that is not Hussein we can
please let's finish on the Palestinian
issue because I'd like to go read this
is an emergency but she's an emergencies
in years and years and we all try to do
so and we'll succeed but well it was not
the reason and he's not an explanation
all right calling gruffy this was a
point that was raised a great deal and
the terrorists in their messages and so
on bring up this issue of the
Palestinian question Bush administration
didn't really address that the problem
with that argument is that if that were
really the case
why didn't a Solomon bin Laden pause all
of the planning for 9/11 when Clinton
was on the brink of trying to make a
breakthrough with Arafat that wasn't the
point of 9/11 that wasn't what they were
gearing through the whole Middle East
crisis is a red herring to drive
attention away from the dictators and
tyrants across the Middle East
there's no doubt that the United States
lost an opportunity to get global
sympathy there's no doubt that al Qaeda
had very little to do with the
Palestinian issue but that misses the
point that the general support out there
for doing things that are violent
against the West is fed by the
stagnation of the Palestinian issue even
if al-qaeda did not rely on that for its
own influence the fact that it's still
out there
getting worse does nothing for our
counterterrorism campaign was mentioned
by both of them the opposition and that
was this connection between 9/11 in Iraq
there was no connection between 9:00 and
11:00 in Iraq and the Bush
administration never made that case they
said specific ladies ladies and
gentlemen read anything on what the Bush
administration has written anything and
you will see that they said what is the
connection after 9/11 it's al Qaeda and
it's Afghanistan does it have any
connection in Iraq no it doesn't so
therefore do we do both together
no because it's only about Al Qaeda and
Afghanistan after that happened after
that that's when Bush looked around and
said all right we have a rogue country
as Jeremy Greene stock has said that has
been in violation of 16 UN resolutions
under Chapter 7 which means use force if
necessary
and the conclusion was do you let
someone who we know has been a threat
not to the America but what's the world
do you let that stand after 9/11 so the
administration never made the connection
that it was that it was a separate
threats you brought that up let's just
go to the audience on that specific
question of September the 11th and
no connection between those attacks and
Iraq who wants to address that point
specifically that calling Rafi was just
raised there a professor graphi is
simply right there was no connection
between the terrorists of 9/11 and Iraq
but there was a connection between the
issue of terrorism and Iraq in this
sense
dr. krishna of whom I'm a great admirer
is mistaken in count opposing the war on
terror - a war on poverty and illiteracy
because the terrorists of 9/11 were not
poor and they were not from a poor
region but the variable most closely
connected with terrorism is a lack of
political openness whereby dissent
migrates to the mosque and radicalism is
incubated that was the connection
between Iraq and 9/11 so there was a
terror threat from Iraq but not linked
to 9/11 my question is you mentioned the
drone attacks were successful in
stopping training camps but you fail to
mention how many civilian lives have
been lost as a result of those drone
attacks are we meant to just look the
other way and pretend like Pakistani
lives aren't valuable
okay well we'll link that question to
the other one earlier on about these
wannabe oncea the drone attacks on
Pakistan in your view on that General
Musharraf and then Cornyn gravely
certainly it goes it is not in
Pakistan's interest and drone attacks
are as this young lady has said they are
causing collateral damage therefore
there is a great public outcry against
the drone attacks and also may I say
there is a public outcry because it
violates the sovereignty of Pakistan
however we I do not say that we should
not attack the terrorists whenever a
target is identified we need to adopt
measures to attack that target those
militants through means which will avoid
collateral damage and ensure the
sovereignty of Pakistan the fact is is
that any loss of life of is of course
horrible but the drone attacks are on
technology that allows the most
exact and precise targeting that we've
ever known in history and so if you were
looking at the various means of military
use the drones are going to have the
least effect on the civilian population
of anything else remember what the
motion is up to mr. green Stockman mr.
Kirchner Bernard policing was the policy
of most Western governments up to 9/11
it failed miserably I'd like to hear
what you have to say about that yeah we
haven't discussed the actual region in
our pider gave for attacking which was
the presence of US troops in the Holy
Land in Saudi Arabia and in order to
respond to being attacked by that they
could either have left as they did from
Lebanon in 1986 fearing more terror or
they could have stayed and I think it's
fairly clear that the Saudi Kingdom
would have been greatly endangered or
they could leave in victory and not have
to protect Saudi from Saddam anymore I'm
curious watch the advocates of law
enforcement were tame was the
non-violent way of making the troops in
Saudi redundant well the Americans did
withdraw their base from Saudi Arabia
didn't they yeah okay we'll put that
question to the panel let's take some go
ahead I wish to ask her pervez musharraf
do you think Osama bin Laden came back
to Pakistan after you were removed
deposed and prior to when you were still
in government in Pakistan do you think
Osama bin Laden was in Yemen where there
is his family come from and there's a
very strong Islamic following okay one
there and then we'll go to the panel my
question actually is to Professor grothy
you said that military dictators were
one of the sort of root causes of
terrorism that they sucked the air after
the democratic process and that in many
ways to depose them you needed direct
Western intervention and kind of boots
on the ground I wasn't there would you
reconsider that statement following the
aftermath of events in Libya where
despite you know NATO air cover the
fight has mainly been waged by the
Libyan people there have been no direct
Western intervention in terms of
and a dictate has been successfully
overthrown with a period of relative
order
unlike in Iraq where there were hundreds
of thousands of troops and their best
thing to be eternal chaos after it at
least in first several years okay very
briefly then first of all Colleen graphy
I mean just would Saddam Hussein of corn
in the Arab Spring to think thank you
very much for that question I think you
misunderstood what I said my point was
that Iraq and Afghanistan were the
catalyst for these other countries that
with the fall of Saddam Hussein it
allowed these other countries to see a
different vision of what the Middle East
could be like and so therefore I
entirely agree with you all of these
things should be homegrown and we need
to work so hard now on developing civil
society rule of law and good governance
saying the Arab Spring would not have
happened unless Iraq and Afghanistan
were in fact saying that Iraq was the
catalyst as I read from Walid John blood
this was something that had never yet
seems it whether you're extrapolating
from what well he's Jim Blatt said no
worries well unit 9 these close to
Saddam he goes to Bashar al-assad should
you say who a legion blood is of course
is the veteran Druze leader in Lebanon
been there several times came and now
are you saying things quite clearly that
without Iraq and Afghanistan being
invaded and Saddam Hussein in the
Taliban going that we would not have
seen the Arab Spring and Ben Ali leaving
and so quite clearly that Iraq and
Afghanistan were the catalyst for what
we're seeing today a catalyst yes do you
agree with that stone for the Arab
Spring I am the partner to Colleen so I
would not like to be in a difficult
situation we can work one sentence on
the Arab Spring the Arab Spring was a
spontaneous reaction by people empowered
by the availability of information
knowing what was going on in the rest of
the world against their government
stealing freedom and national wealth
from
on this particular point the catalyst
which took 8 years though didn't it from
2003 to but anyway yes and that's the
catalyst to veer off in a revolution was
2005 Palestinian was before that I mean
it's it's in steps in progress it
doesn't happen overnight look at the
Berlin Wall on this point about
Afghanistan terror and the invasion of
Iraq and Afghanistan was the catalyst
for seeing the Arab Spring in these
dictators falling agree with what Jeremy
said this is a fantastic movement Arab
Spring spontaneous in a way that we were
waiting for Muslim brothers or
extremists etc and the people all the
people what we call the civil society
rejected their dictator and don't let's
say mixed all the countries Tunisia was
not a ship was not Libya et cetera and
we don't have time to make but the
specific point is people said Saddam
Hussein has gone from power and that in
a way encourages us to also seek now in
Iraq look this is not the miracle I did
what Saddam Hussein was a dictator he
was a killer and now there is a
president of Iraq with occurred this is
a good success the Shiite the majority
of the people are in power against the
minority the Senate this is another
success but it will take time and for
the time being democracy a sort of
democracy not under the British or the
swedish or the french democracy it
step-by-step
it will be done but it does not started
anything okay don't remember you made
that point in her face michele basement
yeah yeah but you I did General
Musharraf has decided General Musharraf
has decided to comment on this specific
question I was trying to answer another
point of view this I I I don't find it
very logical to link Afghanistan or what
we did in Afghanistan in response to
9/11 with Iraq
here was a situation in Afghanistan was
that al Qaeda with
hoovy equate with terrorism carried out
the 9/11 attack and many people are on
terror and your fourth emotion that the
war on terror was the right responded
Iraq was also a terror threat you said
and therefore it was the legitimate
target in the war on terror that's what
she said so just very quickly General
Musharraf was Iraq part of the war on
terror should it have been well I'm I
personally was certainly against the war
in Iraq but I am NOT linking it with
attack on terror really all right
we had that questions the Jeremy green
stock on the policing of crimes and of
terrorism and the policy had failed that
question said policing failed miserably
that's right yeah and things were missed
before 9/11 both internationally and in
the United States but I think this panel
must make the point that over the last
ten years and particularly in the last
few years our police our agencies in the
United States the UK and elsewhere have
done an absolutely fantastic job in
protecting us against repetitions of 7/7
and other terrorist attacks earlier in
the decade let's give the police and the
agencies the real credit that they
deserve for protecting
and
a comment about the the bases in Saudi
Arabia I just want to remind that why
were the US bases in Saudi Arabia to
protect the Kurds in the north and the
Shia and the South in Iraq and the
no-fly zones and so there we were trying
to assist and this is turned against the
United States as being in the land of
Saudi Arabia so as a reminder that's
that's why we were there and the idea
that we should be attacked on 9/11
because we're in Saudi Arabia when were
there to protect the people in Iraq is
an nonsense and General Musharraf did
Osama bin Laden who of course was killed
by the u.s. Navy SEALs in May and a bat
abide in Pakistan did he go to Pakistan
after you left office well I can't I
can't be sure I wasn't tracking him
certainly but he was there in after Abad
as far as I'm concerned whenever anyone
asked me where he is
I always said I don't know he could be
anywhere he's probably more likely on
the Pakistan earth company insisted that
he's in Pakistan then I used to say what
is the information where did you get
this information from he could be
anywhere he could be in Afghanistan or
even outside of Coniston so that was
what he was yes indeed absolutely I was
shocked that he was inept about I mean
living quite openly in a city just a few
miles from not very not very openly
wasn't in an urban area
he wasn't living in a remote farm it was
quite a big townhouse he was living in
quite conspicuous the best place the
safest place is in the thickly populated
place this is a town all too rich into
the mountains of Pakistan go through
after birth a population of 600,000
people and there are civilian and
military people all mixed and tear
together but President at least you
better recognize that he was benefiting
I mean Bin Ladin of some complicity this
is impossible to believe that he was
isolated close to the barracks and close
to the army and etc so I understand your
answer but honestly I certainly would
like to react to this I mean after all
slippage is or poor performance by the
intelligence are possible if you reflect
back to 9/11 how is it that you team
people were being trained for months and
CIA was asleep the most powerful
organization how was it that for
aircrafts for airliners are being
hijacked from four different airfields
and a CIA doesn't know how is it that
through three of them going to the World
Trade Center and the Pentagon CIA is
asleep so let us allow and I decide to
have been sleeping one second on six
from student and I've got a question for
: Rafi I was talking about the origins
of terror due to Arab dictators you
think that's a fair assumption based on
the fact that your government propped up
these dictators Mubarak billions of
dollars second only to Israel which
imposes attorney on the Palestinians and
let's not forget Saddam Hussein was an
American client while she was fighting
your war against Iran okay all right
remember the motion everybody
as you make your points admirably short
will remember the motion yes I just want
to bring it back to the motion I've got
a question for the four panel got a
question for the against panel for the
four panel and please give a direct
answer to this
I don't think let's separate the name
war on terror from the substance of what
actually happened I don't think we can
divorce the symbolisms or the abysmal
failures of the decade
do you support number one extraordinary
rendition to torture as part of this war
on terror
do you support number two detention
without charge in the case of Guantanamo
for over ten years and do you support
number three invasion and occupation of
countries without authorization from the
UN for the against panel against panel I
personally and Quilliam the line we push
is we don't see a polarization between
necessarily between military action on
the one hand and law and order on the
other there's a middle way we think
there's a third way and that's to
empower civil society as demonstrated by
the Arab Spring so would you please
elaborate on what could have been done
to in that third way to empower civil
society rather rather than take military
action thank you okay thank you that's
the quickest four questions I've heard
in about a minute tens better so let's
pick up then panel the point made by the
representative from the Quilliam
foundation which I think was mostly to
your side mr. Musharraf and Colleen
graphy which was when you support the
war on terror do you support detention
without charge
do you support rendition and the
invasion of countries without proper UN
authorization well the question had
several different parts the first is
torture
no that is not allowed the international
community has torture convention but
every country is going to as Britain has
done is going to find ways of
interrogation that come pretty close and
in the United States the view was that
the actions taken and waterboarding were
not tortured now you can disagree with
that a lot of people do
I mean yeah what you described is an
interrogation say stop that and they
considered that it was wrong to do okay
the other with detention every country
is dealing with the difficulty the
tensions between protecting societies
and protecting civil rights so the UK is
in the same situation control orders how
long do you hold people France has a
similar situation and Jeremy the
question to the your side from the
Quilliam Foundation was what what do you
do to empower civil society what's the
alternative to the war on terror how
would you done it
well civil society is actually doing
more than governments in my view at the
moment to make the developing world a
better place
village by village town by town region
by region they don't need to be told
what to do by governments they don't
need to be empowered in what they have
the will to to achieve in the less
advantaged areas of the world but they
do need to work with the governments of
the developing world to be allowed
access to the people who need their help
and when you get that kind of
partnership between what the West in its
donor mode can give and what the
developing world can absorb and receive
and act on you are getting a partnership
that does far more to deal with security
issues than the direct use of military
force that's what we're trying to say
thank you very much for that sir Jamie
Greene store I've got the result now of
the vote after the debate and it's very
interesting all right let me first of
all remind you how you voted audience
before the debate started for the motion
the war on terror was the right response
to 9/11 179 4 323 against there were 200
of you
No so after the debate this is how you
voted for the motion the war on terror
was the right response 276 so you did
gain some against however 402 went down
to 46 so congratulations to the winners
congratulations
[ __ ]
so thank you very much indeed panel
Thank You audience here at Cadogan Hall
in central London and you at home
wherever you are for watching and you
can get a free briefing if you want to
by going to the website wwhen telogen
square dot-com and just follow the
instructions there but for me is a napa
dari from this intelligence squared
debate marking this important occasion
of the 10th anniversary of the September
the 11th attacks thank you very much
goodbye
you
you